hello how you doing good man how are you
I'm pretty good man thank
you uh okay first what I just want to
start off with obviously I'm like not
the most knowledgeable person I'm not
like a professional debator or anything
I'm just a young man just studying right
now but like I have I have a nice common
amount of knowledge like Common Ground
good okay that's something I can work
with sorry that's that's something I can
work with
all right and uh second thing I want to
say is like I respect you a lot as like
you always like I watch your debates
frequently and you always talk with
respect and unlike Sam Shan come on man
you I can't you started off good but you
use this opportunity to try to take a
shot at Sam
man none of that bro I respect the way
you do things I appreciate that then
just leave it at that you ain't got to
take a shot of nobody else just just
that's not really a shot that is a shot
so would you disagree with me so let's
yeah I disagree with you I love how Sam
does things all right so is he flawed
sure he knows that he's a he's a hater
you know he's a hater and a loser you
know but I love how he does things man I
love it I love how he does things um now
what uh what do you have to to bring
today so I read the the title I'm
guessing is proof G was most for $2,200
but I don't really care about the money
be honest okay maybe I can I can give it
to a mosque or a mjid or something like
that whatever you want but uh okay so
first things first let's cover the basis
on the literal definition of the term
Muslim you know what that is I'm
assuming youly it's submitting his will
to
God submitting your will to God okay so
do you deny that Jesus submit his will
to God can we break down what that what
you mean by that first before I answer
that sure how how do you want to break
it down if I say I submit my will to God
but the god that I'm talking about is a
tree in my backyard that I submit to in
worship and I call
God submitting your will to the one true
God because do you believe that the god
of Muslims the god of Muhammad is the
same God of Abraham the same God as
Moses of Moses absolutely not you don't
agree with that no and I and through
this conversation you'll see you'll see
what this is actually why I say Jesus is
not a Muslim because I I what I see is
that Jesus believed in a different God
than what we find in Islam so that's
that's why that's why I was like you
know when you asked do I believe that
Jesus submitted to God I needed to
preface that before I answered it
because I do I believe he submitted to
God but not the god that you're talking
about all right so who can you explain
who the God I'm talking about is so like
for example Allah of the Quran he some
some key characteristics of him he is
not a Trinity right he's absolutely
singular in his in his Essence wasn't
that the same as the Moses's God or
Abraham's God no they wer it wasn't a
Triune God no he's Triune yeah he's
Triune I can show you that later on
depending on how this conversation goes
I'd love to show you that but that later
on so Allah is not trying
Allah doesn't beget nor is he begotten
right he's not a father in any sense to
anyone we're just everybody's just his
servants right his slaves right yeah and
he has no partners he has no companions
no none of that he's not equal to
anybody there's nobody like so these so
these are just some
key characteristics that identifiers of
Allah that we can point out so which one
do you disagree with though I disagree
with the one that he that he has no uh
that God has no sons that he doesn't
beget yeah but is it a characteristic of
God to have children According To Jesus
yes this is this is why this is why I
say he's he can't be a Muslim because
he's talking about a different God than
than what I see in
the but right now since obviously God
throughout all of time did not change
like the god from Adam is the same as
the god of Abraham is the same of God of
the m Moses and same of God of Jesus
same of God of Muhammad not I always all
right you disagree with that but I agree
with that but well for the argument sake
let's talk about it yeah he always had a
son always so was was this son ever
mentioned like in the old I know there
was prophecies about Jesus a lot of
prophecies fulfilled yeah
but is yes he's mentioned in the Old
Testament yes yeah yes and in Aramaic
the Hebrew the definition and he sorry
Hebrew the definition of uh father is
Aba and it has two context to it a
familial context and a higher power
context and what I I believe at least
the term ABA in like the Old Testament
or the New Testament whenever it is
being used it's referring to a higher
power if that makes sense well well they
used it for their family but yes they
called God their father God was their
father would you agree the fact that ABA
or father would have two contexts in
Hebrew uh no I I would just say that the
word father in general just has you know
depends on who you're talking to or what
context has a sense of the word in which
he is a father to that particular person
so um in ABA you know you can have your
you know an adoptive ABA um spiritual
ABA or or a literal begotten Abba you
know so but the word is is is the same
regardless its father just there's
different senses of of of who you know
what a father can be or how or how
they're a father so you disagree with
the fact that ABBA was used or referred
to like a higher context as well no no
you're you're you're you're missing it
ABBA is not is not um it's not like some
word exchanged for God for example
that's that's it wasn't word exchanged
for God yeah it so a common phrase used
sorry go you have Aloha which is God and
you have ABAB which is father right and
so they was they called him his father
he identified and revealed himself as
their father and
that
yes so like and the old Testament God
revealed himself not as like or or
anything it was just revealed himself he
revealed himself as both he revealed
himself as God and he revealed himself
as their
father and that is in the Old Testament
yeah that's in the Torah brother yeah
okay but like from what I read honestly
like I didn't really dig much deep into
the older languages and all that like as
I said I'm just like I'm just going
through University right now don't have
as much i' like but from what I saw I
saw that ABA was also used to refer to a
higher power it's just like a because
there two two context as I said earlier
that's that's incorrect because it
sounds like what you're saying is I I
mean it I don't even know what you even
are meaning anymore are you saying that
that ABA is used for a higher power are
you saying that the word ABA is just
exchanged for the word God is that what
you're saying no no it's not it's not
just exchanged for the word God but it's
like a like let's say a Sim or like a
metaphor uh used to describe like their
Rel their relationship with God yeah
okay all right that that's fine so God
is their father in some sense yes in a
and like I guess in uh but Allah's not
Allah's not a father at all in any sense
look in Islam we don't believe God is a
father in the sense where he has
children no you don't believe you don't
believe he's a father in any
sense yeah like but I guess in the sense
where he is the creator of all is
similar to how a father is like the
creator of his children but you don't
believe that that's what that's what I'm
saying you believe he's Creator but you
do not believe he's father like you
could you like the yeah we don't we
don't believe he's a literal father yeah
no no that stop saying literal you do
not believe as a Muslim that Allah is a
father at all in any sense literal
metaphorical figurative
analogically you anotic you do not
believe as a Muslim that Allah is a
father in any sense doesn't matter how
you mean it in no meaning is Allah a
father okay so to to say otherwise would
be going outside of Islam that's my
point to say otherwise would be going
outside of his how why would saying it
metaphorically saying like he is he is
our creator metaphorically he's like our
father why would that be so for example
I got you brother so in chapter S verse
100 verse 180 of the Quran okay wait
hold on chapter let me open that
seven yeah go on
so it
says and the most beautiful names belong
to Allah so call upon Him by them and
leave the company of those
who beely or deny his names right or
deviate that's what the word is in the
Arabic is those who deviate from his
names they will be uh requited for what
they used to do so Allah so Allah has
names that he
revealed right you are to call upon Him
by those
names and to deviate for those names
you're due for a
punishment father is not one of those
names yeah so to identify him as father
in any way you're deviating and
therefore will be due for a punishment
if you do that okay fair enough
yeah so that's that's what I'm saying as
a Muslim you cannot believe in any way
shape or form that Allah is a father or
refer to him as such you just it just
it's wrong to do so
islamically yeah to be honest uh like I
as I said earlier I wasn't really I'm
not that all no yeah yeah we just
talking man it's all good we're just
talking that's something you know
something new to think about that's what
we here for right yeah I never really
thought of God as a father in any sense
but I was thinking about it like
twisting not twisting words but like
using it seeing metaphorically I guess
or you was trying to twist it you trying
to twist the words I like I was trying
to like not not literally
twist got
him it have slipped
out because my original point was me uh
back then Alba was used for a higher
power but uh okay sure maybe maybe it
was maybe it wasn't
um so this so this is this is my point
my point is is that
since this is this goes against Islam
right so for Jesus when he prayed and he
said he came to do the will of the one
who sent him his father he prayed
calling God his father he said he's the
son of God right who came down from
heaven all of these things shows that
his beliefs do not line up with Islam
and therefore is not a
Muslim but I I view his beliefs to like
let's say let's for can we forget the
father part uh for now and then look at
his the rest of his beliefs or do you
want to stick to that sure we can we can
move on to other beliefs sure okay so I
like from Jesus's beliefs I believe he
followed like Islamic beliefs in the
sense he Jesus didn't eat pork Jesus
fasted when Jesus prayed he Prost to the
ground put his head on the floor let's
wait hold on do not mention so when you
when you talk about
when you talk about praying and stuff
you cannot bring that up because
remember it it matters who you're
praying to right yeah so if he's
prostrating to his father that doesn't
line up with Islam so don't use that as
an example let's let's bring up
something else the example sh uses the
way he prayed is more similar to how
Muslims prayed no that's how Orthodox
Christians pray they prostrate they
prostrate they put their on the floor
prostrate yes
H is that just the Orthodox that do that
no all Christians do it they just it's
more it's more customary in Orthodox
Christianity also in the Ethiopian
church
too okay us to be I didn't know that but
uh and when uh but you mentioned you
mentioned his his diet you mentioned his
diet he doesn't eat pork didn't you poor
so let's so let's talk about Jesus's
diet if it if it matches the diet of a
Muslim was M died of a Jew I know that
he was a Jew follow Jewish Traditions
exactly so as a Jew there he didn't for
like for example he didn't eat
cam but in Islam cam is is it's it's
it's allowed yeah it's allowed yeah so
Jesus's diet doesn't even match that of
a Muslim
right yeah I mean not God necessarily it
match up to have one similarity bro
doesn't mean that you know oh well that
this shows that he's fallowing falling
in the lines of Islam like no but then
like go ahead look the core rules I
believe for that all the messengers got
would always follow but then the other
smaller minor minor rules could change
throughout time uh for the period it
comes to correct you said the minor
rules so are you saying that yeah time
and place are you saying that diet is a
minor
rule in terms of the camel meat in
ancient Arabia they didn't have much uh
like they were limited to their Foods
would you agree with that not really but
let let me even Grant like that that
doesn't have anything to do with this if
you're saying are are you saying that M
that dietary laws are minor and you know
can be changed in time
not necessarily minor but to each place
and to each time those minor rules could
possibly not my those secondary rules
could change i' consider the first rules
the M most important rule rule is one
God uh pray to one God like but it's
about who that God is then if you're
talking about the major rules it's about
worshiping and praying to the true God
who Jesus says is his father so if he if
he has different identity of who God is
that literally goes against Islam then
it's the end of it right there who cares
how he ate or even how how he fasted if
his identi if his concept of God
conflicts with Islam that's where it
matters
right yeah and which we see it does he
says he's the son of
God and uh other than the father what
differ like what differs what you
consider the father to what I consider
like the one and only God other than him
having a a begotten son like uh yeah
other than that like is there any major
differences between them would you say
yeah yeah there's a huge difference yeah
absolutely like what so so for example
uh this is what Jesus says let's go to
what Jesus says
[Music]
here all right so Jesus says here that
uh for as the father raises the dead and
gives them life so also the son gives
life to whoever he
wants for the father judges no one but
has given all judgment to the
son that all may honor the son just as
they honor the
father and whoever does not honor the
son does not honor the father who sent
him so another huge difference is not
just that the father has a begotten son
but that this son is the one who judges
the son gives and raises life whenever
he wants to whoever he wants and he is
to be honored the same way to the same
extent that the father is honored which
means through worship service prayer and
adoration so the same way you honor God
the father is the same same way you're
supposed to honor the
son that is a huge difference what you
say that is a huge difference but which
is why I don't take the Bible to be
credible because I don't believe that is
a genuinely like a genuine true law that
was given to Jesus
and you done hit the button ladies and
Gentlemen let's go ahead and get into
our next segment of
ladies and gentlemen we are back with
another one we have our contestant here
his name is Nazar and we are in the time
of what is the inel now our friend here
says that there are reasons why he
doesn't take the gospel that we have
today as the actual law the inil that
was given to Jesus because of certain
things that obvious L disagree with
Islam so because he's saying that this
isn't what the original law was that was
given to Jesus that means that he knows
what it is in the first place so then
tell me naar we fall in here what is the
inil then if what I just read is not
it the inil was the scripture that was
given to
Jesus but but what is that because
you're saying that the scripture that I
just read that I believe is the Gospel
of Jesus you're saying this isn't it so
then what is it do you believe that the
gospels that you have today was given by
God to Jesus well let's let's talk about
this for a second the angil although
initially given to Jesus was it given to
Jesus in book form or did he just was it
like just an oral
Revelation to be honest I can't tell you
like I as I said I'm not that
knowledgeable uh I don't think I don't
think it's going to be book form I think
it's just oral Revelation similar to
homo like from my assumption at least
which that could totally be wrong you're
actually right actually you're actually
right that is the Islamic view of the
inil and how it came and also that is
also the Christian view of the Gospel
that Jesus came preaching an oral
message he didn't have a book he wasn't
walking around with a book he didn't
have anything written down he went
around preaching the gospel of the
kingdom of God now so this is two things
we're in agreements right now or one
thing we're in agreement right now Jesus
preached the gospel orally now yeah was
it written
uh was the Gospel written during the
time of Jesus during any time at all was
it written at
all I I I can't tell you that to be
honest I'm not
sure I can research that and come back
to you later but I got you dude dude
look I I I want you to know here right
now one I love your humility you've been
humble from the start and you're
continuing to be humble which is it's a
breath of fresh air man you and Paradox
the last guest I like both of you guys
so keep this keep keep this attitude man
um but so the parts that you don't know
if I do know I'll help you right which
which is what I'm here for so in the
Quran it says in chapter 1 7 well oh
yeah we're still in chapter 7 we'll go
to uh verse 157 this time yeah so
157 chapter 7 verse
157 all right soorry just give me one
second let me open that do you read 15
yeah do you read Arabic at all I do read
aric oh nice that's good okay but yeah
157 yeah here I'm opening that
up yeah got it all right so it's kind of
a lengthy verse most of it doesn't have
anything to do with the point um all
right so it says those who follow the
messenger the prophet who can neither
read nor write whom they find written in
the Arabic is Makin right written yeah
with them in the torat and
the right
so so so from this we can see that the
inil was written and the Christians had
it with them yeah okay so this answer
our the question was the inil written
the answer is yes now it doesn't tell us
when it was written it just tells us
that it was right so we don't know when
it was written written um but let me ask
you this if you had to take an educated
guess who do you think would have
written the gospel that Jesus was
preaching uh his disciples I agree with
you 100% that's the Christian view he
says this is another thing we agree on
so we agree that Jesus preached the
gospel orally we agree that uh it was
written down eventually and we agree
that his disciples would have been the
ones who wrote it down but can I say
where I would probably differ with you
on sure so the the disciples they when
they wrote the gospels they wrote it
from their eyewitnesses like their
eyewitnesses their uh their view of
things correct okay sure uh would you
agree with that or uh yes I would say
that they they wrote it through their
eyewitness testimony and recorded the
things that he said and did yes so then
what they wrote down could not be God's
words because that was their own
eyewitnesses correct not necess neily
not I I would say it wouldn't be God's
words verbatim but God could have
inspired them to write exactly what they
wrote how they wrote it which the Quran
the Quran kind of alludes to this the
Quran says in chapter five it says we
inspired the
disciples um to believe in Jesus and
stuff like that so they had the
inspiration of God even according to the
Quran yeah I I I I I agree with that the
fact that the disciples wrote it but
then when you look at it the oldest uh
the oldest version of the New Testament
the Cod codex catticus
uh I'm pretty sure it's codex caticus I
might be uh messing up the name that's
the that's the oldest complete that's
the earliest complete uh New Testament
that that we found yeah that was four
centuries after Jesus yeah but but the
man we have manuscripts that go before
that but they're just not compil but the
earliest manuscript was 70 to 90 ad okay
what's the problem with that
so what happened in those first 70 to 90
years before the manuscripts came came
70 AD is not 70 years Jesus Jesus
ascended to heaven in about 33 ad so 70
AD would be just just under 40 like 40
then it's 40 to 60 years the earliest
manuscripts right and those are copies
which means that what they're copied
from existed earlier than that yeah and
but do you do do we have any idea of the
people who copied it any any information
on them well we do but just one second
though okay um because we we need to
figure out what this inil is and if
these things are important to it yeah so
we know that the disciples would have
written the the gospel that Jesus
preached I just like how the comps
exactly exactly so the disciples writing
the Gospel of Jesus
um how do you know that Matthew Mark
Luke and John would not are not the ones
who wrote the
inel uh they it's they could have they
could have wrote it but then what I
believe is whoever those the disciples
that wrote it down over time until like
the early manuscripts did come out I
believe it was skewed okay got you so
then the writings of Matthew Mark Luke
and John are the J just a little skewed
then the skewed in
Jill uh could
be could be
or could could be or could be other
because this is what we can't can't be
otherwise or this is what we don't have
like definitive answers to like it could
have been other uh Disciples of Jesus
who wrote it because with Matthew Mark
John do we have but how would you
know well like in that sense we won't
find out until the day of judgment well
no because I mean all we have in in all
of Christian history is that the gospel
was written down by Matthew Mark Luke
and John that's what we have for all for
2,000 years of Christian
history but we don't have much
information on Matthew Mark Luke and
John like for for example can I just
show a comparison not really that that
doesn't matter because not having
information or knowing fully knowing
everything about Matthew Mar and John
doesn't change the fact that they wrote
it uh yeah it doesn't change the fact
that they wrote it so that's that's what
I'm saying all that extra information is
is irrelevant it's
absolutely like at least for islamically
how we view things is for the people the
the sahabas whom wrote the Quran yeah
who wrote the Quran through oral
tradition and all that we it wasn't just
any any companions it was like the most
knowledgeable the most trusted companion
compion it wasn't the most trustworthy
companions a matter of fact matter of
fact dude one of the most trusted
trusted Companions of Muhammad was IB
masud IB M was one of the people
Muhammad said you need to learn the
Quran from him he named four I mud was
the first one he named IB masud had
nothing to do with the writing of the
Quran the rewriting of it whenman
rewrote the Quran and then burned the
other copies I M had do with that the
manuscripts started coming out during
the time of Abu be when Zade ended up
yeah Z ended up uh collecting collecting
you right yeah but then but then so with
Zade collecting the Quran during the
time of Abu Bakr if that was all good
then why in the world would there have
been a issue in the time of utman if
they had one Quran that everybody was
good with why would they have a problem
okay so you see the Quran was still
obviously after during Abu bakr's time a
lot of the companions who had the the
ones who had that memorized died yeah
during Abu bak's time right yeah during
Abu bakr's time during
the yeah a lot of the died so that's
when he got Zade to compile it then
during the time ofman which I'll get to
right now during the time ofman Islam
started spreading throughout like the a
lot like they started spreading a lot
correct sure
and when when it starts spreading to the
different areas in the that spoke Arabic
but different dialects of
Arabic uh and it would be spread a lot
of the times through oral tradition
still because oral tradition was the
these weren't these were not these were
not dialectical issues these were things
that were written down in people's Quran
that mam that um I'm sorry thatman had
them turn in their copies of the Quran
to burn them so that he
and rewrote the other Quran how did
people write the Quran first they would
listen to it orally and then they would
end up writing it down for the most part
at least so then my question is by the
time utman comes here why is there a
issue with the textual Quran since Abu
Bakr had it collected by the most
trusted Companions of Muhammad the ones
who are most knowledgeable Why by the
time we get to Usman there is a problem
with the Quran to where the brother one
of the brothers say oh chief of the
Believers to utman save this
people um from deferring about the book
before they differ like the Jews and the
Christians did
before so it's that bad to where they it
could split the religion that's how
worried they were yeah I'm not denying
that it got bad because over time over
the spread of Islam a lot more people
are accepting Islam it's prone it's more
prone to being skewed more prone to
being like what similarly to what no not
if not if there is a standardized text
right yeah but the standardized text
didn't come until the time of no no dude
there was a standardized text in Abu
bakr's time that's when it first came
the one that Zed compiled yes so before
utman there was a standardized text
that's what I'm saying yes so since
there's already a standardized text why
then by the most knowledgeable and
trusted companions why would by the time
U man comes there's a problem with the
text there there was a standardized text
but it wasn't fully compiled into one
book it was compiled in the one book
that's what they did it was no it wasn't
fully compile because and it wasn't
there wasn't major copies of it it
wasn't spreading through that it was
still spreading through oral tradition
yeah yes they were writing it down they
copied and wrote it down
but what was doing because it was
spreading mainly through oral tradition
up until the time of when saw that the
Quran uh through oral tradition when it
started spreading to other areas in the
world you're missing a a huge point one
of the points in the Hadith it says
whenman had them turn in their
qurans they was turning it in so they
had copies of the Quran but that what
I'm saying how do you think they got
copies of the Quran they wrote them they
copied they wrote them yes correct they
wrote them they wrote them and how do
you think they got the like and
companions not companions the new
Muslims in new areas they're not in new
areas they're not in in new areas
they're in the same area
isman but no no no the Arab yeah they're
all in AR no somewhere in Iraq the main
uh the main Quran uh that started the
Quran where it started being different
was in Iraq
mainly this is where this is where the
issue is bro in the the issue is is that
you have a problem with the Quran early
on where if it's supposed to be all good
and dandy by the most trusted companions
there shouldn't be a problem to where
you now have to burn the rest of the
Quran and read write it okay can can I
finish my point or I I want you to
respond to that because that's that's
where we we that's the Crux of this I
was on I was on the verge of answering
this okay all right please answer
directly then so you uh they handed in
literal books of the Quran they wrote
correct
yep and how do you think they wrote that
Quran how do you think that the verses
came to them like let's say the companis
in
kufa who
knows through oral
tradition
okay and then when companions listen to
the Quran themselves how do you know
that it come how do you know that it's
coming through oral
tradition that was the main way that the
Quran was spread not necess before the
before the time of it was mainly spread
through oral tradition so people had
copies of the Quran through oral
tradition like there were the copies of
the Quran the literal text of the Quran
wasn't uh what was the oral what was the
oral tradition based on is what I'm
asking what was it based on do you mean
Bas what was the source of the oral
tradition the source of the oral TR
through it comes through the Companions
and they spread the Quran they memorize
it orally what was their
standard standard of like in order like
how would somebody know if if one of the
companions got a verse wrong how would
another companion be able to objectively
say hey man you actually got this verse
wrong how would he be able to show him
that let's say a companion is reading it
to a group of companions reading it it
reading what not reading it I'm reciting
it to a group of companions sorry so
what would be the objective standard to
say hey man you got actually got this
wrong here the an the not the ancient
sorry the like Arabs at that time their
me their memorizationscripture
wouldn't it be the Quran that they
standardized that they collected and
compiled that would be the standard by
which the Quran is now being orally
transmitted and there should be no
issues
right yeah okay yet issues come
it issues could come but for the most
they did come they did they did come
when the Quran was spread to other areas
which spoke different dialects different
it wasn't it wasn't a dialectical issue
because you even had people of the same
of the same tribe that had issues with
each other like hasham and Omar it
wasn't
dialectical it wasn't a dialect problem
it was a wording problem and a meaning
problem it wasn't no no you're wrong it
wasn't only a dialectical problem but a
dialect problem was part of it no I
disagree dialect problem had nothing to
do with it a dialect when it spread to
other areas it did have something to do
with it okay no worries so we see here
that there's differences the problem is
differences in the Quran and its wording
and its meaning that's causing FNA
amongst the people yeah so when you get
there when you when you when you do all
when you get to this point you now have
mman who's who says bring me all of your
qurans we're going to rewrite one I'm
going to burn all the rest yes because
of do you know do you know which Quran
used to standardize
it yeah the one that was uh given to
what's his
name's daughter which you don't
have uh which is the one thatman used
but we don't have that to know that he
used that do
we we have it through oral tradition and
but you don't know that you don't know
if it traces back to that one you don't
know that there's there's a lot of
different oral Traditions that everybody
would say Trac to that our oral
tradition traces back to the time of
Muhammad peace be upon him no it
doesn't there's there's a chain of
narrations that go date back to Muhammad
like a teacher like from Muhammad's time
Muhammad teaches someone someone teaches
someone and then it goes back to people
now till now yeah I got you I just I
just think that it would it would uh if
we had this type of history in
Christianity if Paul for example were to
um use Luke and T is to collect all the
manuscripts of the gospel and writings
of the Gospel um and the Old Testament
and rewrote it standardized his own um
and and and sent that one out while
burning the rest of the Gospel
manuscripts in the Old Testament R's
manuscript the Tor manuscripts you guys
would have you got no you would have a
field day with that be honest you would
have a field day with that You' be like
see corruption easy no the ma the major
companions all agreed to that one
standardized no they did not I disagree
IB M again IB M disagreed with whatman
was doing having having one person or a
couple people disagree out of thousands
of people is very minor not one one it's
not thousands of them it's not thousands
of main uh Companions of of Muhammad
it's quite a few and there's a few
special there's four special ones four
special ones when it comes to the
knowledge of the Quran IB m is one of
them UB KB is another there's two others
that I'm forgetting but none of the four
were part of the council when it came to
the the standardization of the Quran by
all the major the major companions at
the time
of the majority of would you
disagree UB kab and the two others were
alive at the time what are you talking
about I know I know I'm not saying they
were alive but there's other major
companions other than these ones they're
not they're not the major ones the ones
who know the Quran the
the the only ones that matter are the
ones who know the Quran the best would
you agree yeah no not actually no not
necessarily every single major companion
every single major companion knows it is
what it is dog it is it is what it is if
you don't see if you don't see no it's
all good if you don't see a problem with
this that's fine that's that's on you
you can have every excuse in the book
you want for it it's a clear problem to
me and when you do not have the ones who
Muhammad say learn the Quran from part
of the decision making of the
standardization of the Quran the
correctness of it you have none of them
part of it and you actually have some of
them objecting to it I think that
there's a huge problem there if you
don't see a problem Hey listen there was
only there was only one important there
was only one important person that
objected to what aan is there are a
couple there obviously there a couple
minor people that objected to it but for
the vast majority of all the sahabah
they all agreed to what aan was doing no
they didn't correct no that's incorrect
the vast majority no that's
incorrect can you show me how that thing
CRA well I'll show you on another stream
I'll show you in another stream I'll
bring I'll bring my friend ji and he'll
show you that this is uh he'll show you
the whole Islamic narrative on this and
how it
has I want to get back to our subject
because you know it doesn't matter what
I say to you it doesn't matter even if
I'm Corner how it doesn't matter what I
say you're G to you know can I say one
more thing can I just say one more thing
10 seconds please the standardization of
the Quran was agreed through by many of
the companions obviously and disagreed
by many no disagreed by a little not
many okay it's a a minority got you can
we move on now sure all right so going
back to this in Geo now so Matthew Mark
luk John you agree uh could have written
the NG yeah that's a possibility yeah
and there's no evidence otherwise to
them writing the to them not writing the
in there's no evidence of them writing
it or not writing it there is the
evidence that we have is 2,000 years of
of church history saying Matthew Mark
luk and John wrote the
Gospel of church history yeah of
Christian history and for us as Muslims
we believe that disciples written it but
not not necessarily could have been
other disciples not necessarily M
marthew Matthew Luke and John who you
don't know got it so you don't know and
you have no evidence for that
right yeah got it but so all the the the
evidence points to Matthew Mark Luke and
John if we're looking from a historical
basis right sure okay so we're all the
evidence points to Matthew Mark Luke and
John writing the Gospel of Jesus boom so
it sounds like to me so far you agree
with me that what I have at least is the
Ino to some extent
that well yeah sure look how we how we
see uh the New Testament to be exact
like the true parts of it what matches
with the Quran we believe is a true
Parts what doesn't match what
contradicts the Quran is the false parts
and what's in the middle ground between
contradiction and matches is parts that
could be true parts that could be false
I got you we know the script so here's
my here's my thing with this let me ask
you this do you think that that's like a
that's a fair and hon intellectually
honest position
hold uh a fair and from a Muslim
standpoint no I'm not talking about from
a Muslim standpoint I'm talking
objectively is that an an an
intellectually honest position to hold
objectively to come to the truth of
something if you believe what you have
is the truth it
is okay if I that's that's subjective my
friend I'm I'm talking about OB
objectivity meaning regardless of what
you feel or I feel what you believe or I
believe the facts are the facts the
reality is the reality and so what I'm
saying is objectively do you believe
that that position right there whatever
agrees with the Quran that's good
whatever doesn't agree that's not the
real NGO objectively objectively without
any context obviously it's not a fair
point but then that's why we have the
context what's the
context of obviously how like
Christianity and Islam yeah what's the
context like for example if you're
saying that the Quran is what decides
what the inil is where does the Quran
tell you that where does the Quran tell
you what the injil
is the Quran doesn't go dig deep into
the I I know I I know so that's that's
the problem you can't look in into what
we have and say Oh that's theel oh wait
that part's not the NG because you don't
know what it is you have no reference
point all you're doing is saying oh well
that seems to disagree with the Quran so
that's not what the Quran does say is uh
use the Quran to verify uh the or
something along these lines use to
verify the Scripture it never says that
matter of fact it says the opposite it
says the other way around actually you
want to you want to see it here wait
chapter 10 verse
94 it says this talking to Muhammad
chapter 10 ver
94 if you are in doubt about what have
revealed to you go and ask those who've
been reading the scripture before you be
not of those who
doubt okay wait hold I'm just pulling up
the verse it's either the verse or I
might be mixing them up go to chapter 10
verse 94 just read the verse straight
out I just quoted it no yeah I know I
know that
verse I heard it so do you see how Allah
is telling Muhammad to verify his
Revelation the Quran with the previous
scripture
to verify his was that the does it say
orally like the verse the transmission
of verses orally for the in and the Tor
it says to go and ask those who've been
reading the scripture before you so they
have the text they have the scriptures
the books they've been reading them it's
their tradition and so basically
Muhammad can go back to them to verify
the Revelation he received to make sure
it's correct so that he doesn't have a
reason to
doubt yeah so do you see how based on
the based on the Quran it's the previous
scriptures that are used to verify the
Quran you see that not verify the Quran
it's if uh wait can you read it one more
time because I don't have it pulled up
yet it says if you are in doubt about
what we have revealed to you then go and
ask those who have been reading the
scripture before you be not of those who
doubt
yeah it doesn't that doesn't only verify
the Quran it's just showing that if you
are in doubt you're going to see the
previous scriptures before you you're
going to have similarities especially
but wait who who cares if there's
similarities what is the point of these
similarities do do these similarities
clarify his
doubts these similarities could clarify
your doubts because it shows that these
are people of the book and and these
stories are
accurate the story not all the stories
but a lot of them are accurate it said
oh my God think for me for two seconds
just think with
me think with me think with me think
with
me think with
me if I
say hey Nazar if you ask me a question
about you know how me and your mom met
right how what I'm
sorry if you if you ask your dad a
question about how he and your mom met
sorry bro I did not mean to do
that how your dad and your mom met okay
you ask your dad how how did your dad
and your mom meet yeah okay and your dad
tells you the story of how they
met and you you know you may be qu you
may be qu may be question him a bit
but he says go and ask your mom if if
you're doubting by if you're doubting
what I said go ask your mom go ask your
mom how you how we met and don't and
don't and don't doubt me again what's
the point of his of your dad sending you
to his to your mom about what he
said because the like the main idea of
how they met the main concept is always
going to be the same just like the main
the core ideas of Islam so send so him
sending you to your to your mom is going
to verify what he told you
right
MH so now we're just going to switch
characters now
similarly I got what I want to find for
the thing I was talking about that's
nice but
similarly the Quran Allah says go ask
the people of this book who've been
reading the
scripture if you're doubting the
Revelation I gave to you go go ask
them because what they have is going to
verify what I told you Muhammad right
yeah so it's the previous books that
verify the revelations in the Quran yeah
which verse was that again it's
1094 okay and have you looked into the
other verses uh that are similar to this
that have SE between
them uh yes I have that has nothing to
do with the verse okay but obviously the
t is explained the very best I disagree
a lot of a lot of T A lot of tapers
contradict the
Quran uh a lot of contradict the Quran
like what do you
mean h that's another story
man that's another
story you see I like like for for
example iath I says that you know where
the verse says that Jesus is the word of
Allah I contradicts it and says he's not
the word of Allah but he is created by
the word of Allah so he contradicts what
the Quran PL blatantly says
wait yes yes he he contradicts itally
Jesus is not the word of God yeah he
says he's not the word of Allah but he's
created by the
word and what does the verse say that
that Jesus is the word of Allah he is
Allah's word it says that he is a
messenger of Allah and his word that he
cast down to Mary and a Spirit from
him what that's that's another see I
didn't this is why I didn't want to go
there that's another subject I want
please stay focused on what we're
talking about we'll leave that for
another day so do you see how that the
Quran Allah says that it's the previous
scriptures that verify the Quran you see
that the pr sure yeah so that's why I'm
saying it's wrong to say that the Quran
is what verifies the previous scriptures
because according to the Quran that's
not how it goes it's the previous
scriptures that verify the Quran the
Quran doesn't literally say the previous
scriptures verify it just says if you
are in doubt go to the previous
scriptures but the Quran does literally
say use if you're in doubt why would you
go to the previous scriptures why to do
what what's the point to see to see the
similarities within the core no it's not
to see it's not to see the similarities
it's if you have have doubts why would
Allah why is Allah's answer to Muhammad
who has doubts to go ask the people who
read the scripture before him why how
will that help his doubts those are
people of knowledge of the how will it
help his
doubts how will it help to because it
shows that there is similarities there's
a pattern between them so does it verify
what he was doubting what he might have
been
doubting does it verify what what yeah
sure
so it's the previous scriptures who
verifies the Quran
right it's not the previous scriptures
that verify the
Quran it's the Quran that verifies the
previous
[Laughter]
Scriptures it doesn't it doesn't
literally talk about if you hey look man
I think that that's that is the end of
this I I I can't continue this because
now you know we we we can't move move
forward when you're not honest and um
just yeah so wait before we end this off
that's it because go back to what we
talking about earlier there this is it
if you can't if you can't settle this
there is no go we can't go
anywhere no because the previous
scriptures that we are talking about
like we talked about the earliest
manuscripts of the New Testament if you
can't if you can't be honest with this
verse here you have nothing to say to me
you have nothing to say to me verse
talks says if you are in doubt go to the
people of the previous script if you're
in doubt about
what uh hold on let me pull up the verse
what uh what was the verse again it says
Revelations if you're in doubt about the
Revelation that we've been giving to
you C can you give me the verse 1094 for
the last
time 10
94 hold on
see here Surah unas verse
94 in the third
ver
1094 yeah I'm just reading the read the
verse bro get out of here get
out wait I'm reading the here wasting my
time get out of here absolutely